le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
chaque année à l'occasion de la journée
de la femme le département organise le
prix célimène ce concours a pour
objectif de permettre aux femmes
artistes amateurs de s'exprimer dans les
domaines de la peinture la sculpture ou
la photographie
adélaïde grandin a reçu le prix
d'encouragement de cette édition 2016
cette jeune mère au foyer réalise des
petites maquettes en pâte polymère
depuis son domicile à saint denis
non non c'est la magie s'opère dans le
vert et le blanc apparaître son atelier
une simple table dans un coin du salon
sa matière de prédilection une sorte de
pâte à modeler qui durcit à la cuisson
ça c'est un point de filmer donc ça fait
50 56 g et du coup en fait on a
plusieurs couleurs différentes
ça se trouve en lui et a pressé c'est un
mode de mixer les couleurs de les
mélanger pour en avoir de nouvelles et
puis rapporté des possibilités infinies
c'est à partir de cette pâte qu'adélaïde
a réalisé satie cuisine mais mais une
oeuvre élu coup de coeur du jury lors de
la dernière édition du prix célimène
mais quand quelque chose d'un petit
parce que je fais ça en hommage à
à mes grands-mères et attire les grands
mères et toutes les femmes en fait force
de la réunion
une société un peu
donc voilà je voulais médiane
dunis guêpe opaque et de bougies tout y
est
un travail de précision pourtant
adélaïde ne s'est lancée dans la
création qu'en novembre dernier
j'ai commencé ça quand j'étais sur la
fin de ma grossesse donc ça me
permettait de souffler et de penser à
autre chose et de de m'évader en fait
donc du coup j'ai vraiment fait ça par
loisirs j'ai découvert ça un jour et
puis j'ai commencé je me suis noces et
puis j'y arrivais bien donc on va
continuer un changement de vie radical
avant de devenir maman
la jeune femme était agent de
recouvrement pour un opérateur
téléphonique rien avoir du tout pas très
folichon j'ai toujours aimé travailler
avec mes mains donc que ce soit le
dessin la sculpture
on compterait s'étant terminée à la fin
de ma grossesse j'ai fait le choix
d'être mère au foyer et un et du coup
moi je fais mon petit obligés lève
machine et puis et puis mon conjoint
soutient totalement c'est d'ailleurs
pour sa petite fille qu'adélaïde réalisé
première oeuvre des tableaux à l'univers
poétique et féerique un monde imaginaire
qui alimente encore les créations de la
jeune femme
alors je travaille sur une petite bulle
magique
moi j'aime bien les rues puis j'ai vu
confier dans quinze jours
quand existe en soit j'ai une idée
pendant l'annoncé pendant là je me dirai
pas ce que j'ai fait un dessin animé
puisque ma fille sa fille reste sa
première source d'inspiration et sa
première fan aussi absolument que ce
soit pour le moment
adélaïde et ses proches sont les seuls à
profiter de ses créations est donc pour
moi soit de la famille a réussi un petit
billet en échange on prend m'acheter ans
comme fimo et puis la leur en faire
d'autres
pourquoi pas c'est pour moi l'occasion
la matière première et les équipements
sont assez coûteux pour cuire la pâte à
des lives fait avec les moyens du bord
que vous lui c'est pas c'est pas nocif
en tout cas c'est encore prouvé c'est
pas dit ce prix célimène c'est l'espoir
de transformer un jour son loisir en
activité professionnelle j'espère que
j'aurai peut-être des contacts peut-être
que je
et aussi en tant qu'auto entrepreneur
cependant
chose maintenant oui je n'ai jamais
enseigné dans cette voie là et puis
pourquoi pas faire
ma petite entreprise des puits
l'artisanat local en représentant
le département a créé le prix célimène
en 2005 pour encourager l'expression
artistique des femmes les femmes
artistes amateurs de la réunion n'ont
pas souvent un lieu où elles peuvent
exposer et donc à travers le précéder
mail le département donne la possibilité
à ces femmes artistes amateurs de
pouvoir s'exprimer
on a eu cette année 180 8 femmes qui ont
présenté des oeuvres
preuve que dans le domaine de la
photographie de la sculpture de la
peinture il ya des femmes qui ont des
talents mais qui n'ont pas eu cette
occasion de montrer au public leurs
talents et là le département dans le
christ et du maine leur donne cette
occasion
le prêt célimène est un concours réservé
aux femmes artistes amateurs dans les
domaines de la sculpture de la peinture
et de la photographie
il est ouvert à toutes les femmes de
plus de 18 ans résidant à la réunion
n'ayant jamais participé à une
exposition et n'ayant pas bénéficié de
formation artistique
les dossiers d'inscription sont à
retirer à la fin de l'année auprès de la
direction de la culture et du sport au
39 bis rue du général de gaulle à saint
denis ou à télécharger sur le site du
département www.cglpl.fr
alors